hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his piece the subject and power
michelle fuco has a section
called what constitutes the specificity
of power
relations and when we hear that word
specificity we should be thinking about
getting away from
universals or things that are supposed
to apply
everywhere across the board sort of like
a theory of everything as we say from
the you know 10 000 feet view from above
and instead we have other ways of
talking about this getting granular is a
very contemporary
metaphor for it or we talk about
drilling down usually the metaphor is
from going from the top to the bottom
because we typically think
of the generality being high up and the
specificity being at the level that we
live and foucault begins this section by
saying
listen there's no such thing as
power
as such he says there's no such entity
as power with or without a capital
letter global massive or diffused
concentrated or distributed and then he
goes on to say something really
important power exists now he so he's
saying there is power
but power exists only as exercised by
some on others only when it is put into
action even though of course it is
inscribed in a field of space
available possibilities underpinned by
permanent structures we're going to come
to that possibilities thing in just a
moment
and here he's going to tell us a number
of what power
isn't as he works into his his way of
understanding how we should
grasp power
relations and so he begins by talking
about consent which you notice you know
we can diagram in this way consent would
belong on the side of those who power is
exercised over and he says that power is
not a matter of consent it is not in
itself that's a very important term in
itself the renunciation of freedom
transfer of rights or power of each and
all delegated to a few
now what is he getting at there well
these are some typical ways
of understanding power that
generally come from
modern theories uh modern philosophy and
political theory in particular
where
power is something that is transferred
from those who are governed to those who
govern or rule those who exercise power
you could think of thomas hobbs as being
a prime example of this there is an
original
agreement or compact or contract in
order to preserve one's life and one's
property and freedom that gives power to
a
sovereign and foucault is saying now
listen it's not impossible for that to
happen but that's not really at the core
of power he says there is the
possibility consent may be a condition
for the exercise or the maintenance of a
power relation it can happen there
the relationship of power may be an
effect of a prior or permanent consent
but it's not by nature the manifestation
of a consensus so this doesn't rule
consent out entirely it just says listen
there's a lot of cases where that that
is how power relations are structured
that's not the essence of it
what about going the other direction
looking at the one who rules he says and
looking at some
violence that must have been the
primitive form of power its permanent
secret and last resort that which in the
final analysis appears as its real
nature when it throws aside its mask and
shows itself as what it really is and
then he says well
there's a difference here
what defines a relationship of power
is that it's a mode of action that does
not act directly and immediately on
others so we're going to come back to
this in just a moment how does it act
well on actions he says a relationship
of violence acts upon a body or upon
things it forces it bends it breaks it
destroys
where it closes off possibility its
opposite pole can only be passivity if
it comes up against any resistance it
has no option but to try to break it
down so violence
is not the same thing as power nor is it
its secret origin or as he said it's
last resort when all other things fail
then you punch somebody or you break
them down in some way
that's not to say that violence can't be
part of power just as much as consent
can be part of power but
that is not its core why not
because the power relation as he says
coming back to this
he says
power acts upon their actions upon the
actions of others an action upon an
action
on possible or actual future or present
actions and then he goes on a little bit
further and he says a power relationship
can only be articulated on the basis of
two elements that are indispensable
if it was really to be a power
relationship that the other the one over
whom power is exercised
is recognized and maintained to the very
end as a
subject who acts so in a genuine power
relationship it's not to say that
everything is perfectly balanced or
anything like that or that violence
isn't part of it or that consent isn't
part of it but what's really key to it
is that both sides
are
subjects and are recognized as such that
is subjects who have agency subjects who
can do things i exercise power on you
by getting you to do things that i want
you to do but you are the are the
subject who does it are you a totally
free subject who can you know just jump
out of the power relationship and look
down on it from above not necessarily
although you know perhaps in some power
relationships that could be a
possibility
and so he goes on and he says
the establishing of power relationships
does not exclude the use of violence any
more than it does the obtaining of
consent
no doubt the exercise of power can never
do without one or the other often both
at the same time
but
these consent and violence do not
constitute the principle
or basic nature of power so what is the
basic nature of power he tells us that
it
operates on the
field and here he uses a singular but i
think we could expand this to a plural
fields of possibilities
that the different subjects actually
have which means that there's always
conditions
there's always constraints we exist as
people say in a society usually they're
saying that to remind us not to be jerks
but in this case we can say we're always
within
matrices of possibilities some of which
are closed off for us and some of which
are
opened up for us or even assumed not as
possibilities but just as what one does
and so he goes on and he says
these are fields of possibilities in
which the behavior of active subjects is
able to inscribe itself how does it
inscribe itself by acting by doing
things
inscribe is a sort of you know
writing metaphor right there
it is a set of actions again he says on
possible actions power incites it
induces it seduces it makes easier or
more difficult it releases or contrives
makes more possible or less
in the extreme it constrains or forbids
absolutely but it is always a way of
acting upon one or more acting subjects
by virtue
of their acting or being capable of
action and then he says one more time a
set of actions upon
other actions and i'd like to go back to
this little
sketch of the ways the modalities in
which power
is exercised on this field of
possibilities so he says
it incites inciting is getting something
it's provoking something it induces
similar it subduces it draws
out from the other attempts it
it makes it easier or more difficult
this is a very important one the
phenomenon of nudging in our time can
easily be seen
as a
expression of fukodian power relations
nudging is when you make things just a
little bit more difficult or a little
bit more easy to get people to behave in
certain ways
it releases or contrives makes more
probable
or less other ways in which the
action of another is being
cajoled or being conditioned right
in the extreme as he points out it
constrains or forbids absolutely and
this is where we should jump ahead to
look at something else that he says he
tells us that in the absolute limit of
slavery where there is no freedom
whatsoever
we don't really have power relations
anymore right
he tells us that where the determining
factors are exhaustive there's no
relationship of power
slavery is not a power relationship when
a man is in chains
only when he has some possible mobility
even a chance of escape now he's not
talking about you know oh you've got
chains on you therefore you're at an
absolutely constrained subject you could
take the chains and strangle your
captors you could whip the chains around
and hit your fellow slaves there are
possibilities what he's talking about
there is when somebody is completely
constrained essentially turned into an
automaton
that's no longer a power relationship
that is a relationship merely a violence
or domination right one has been turned
completely into an object
when there is still subjectivity there
being acknowledged and treated as a
subject it is a still a power relation
even if you are in chains
so that's quite important to look at
he also tells us several other important
matters he tells us
that um the equivocal nature of the term
can conduct or conduct is one of the
best aids for coming to terms of the
specificity of power relations to
conduct is at the same time to lead
others right
and then he says and a way of behaving
within a more or less open field of
possibility so the exercise of power
is a conduct of conducts the
subject who is acting
on the side of imposing power the the
you might say dominant subject
is leading is determining is ruling what
the conducts
of the other subject in their action can
be and it's interesting if you think
about
actions as individual actions but also
as tendencies habits
um intentional chains of actions those
are all what we would call
conduct right
so he goes on and he says that
power
is
the exercise of power is a conduct of
conduct and a management of
possibilities it's less a confrontation
between two adversaries or their mutual
engagement than a question of government
and he says we have to be careful with
this word government don't think
automatically the government or the
place where you are
we have to have a very broad sense to
this government did not refer only to
political structures or the management
of states it designated the way in which
the conduct of individuals or groups
might be directed so we can talk about
he says the government of children we
would say nowadays upbringing right
or
of souls that we'd say spiritual
advising or something like that of
communities of families of the sick
it covered not only the legitimately
constituted forms of political or
economic subjection but also modes of
action more or less considered and
calculated that we're destined to act
upon the possibilities of action of
other people so just to pause for a
moment think about when you enter a
restaurant with certain expectations
and you are conducted to a table where
then you are invited to do what anything
you like no you should look at the menu
if the menu has been brought to you and
there's an entire like set of rules that
are completely unwritten how long do you
have to wait for the server to come and
bring you some water and then ask you
what drinks or appetizers you would like
and when do you flag down the manager or
bring somebody else in these are all in
addition to whatever else they may be
power relations at work
right and there's a governmentality
to this which could be superimposed upon
by other governmentalities for example
the existence of health inspectors who
come in and check up on things from the
state or the city right which is
essentially another kind of state as far
as wefuko's talking about so this is a
very rich
concept here this governmentality or
government
so he says the relationship proper to
power would be sought not on the side of
violence or struggle nor that of
voluntary contracts but rather in the
area of that singular mode of action
neither war like
juridicial
which is
government
and he says you know power is the
government of men by other men in the
broadest sense of the term and this
brings us to another key element
freedom
power is exercised only over
free subjects and only insofar as they
are free now notice what foucault says
about this he doesn't mean free in some
sort of abstract sense where everything
they want to do is possible for them and
they can always choose between it's not
that sort of silly nonsense
real freedom is always within
constraints always within possibilities
that we can push against and sometimes
break through
but sometimes push back on us and
constrain us so he says we mean
individual or collective subjects who
are faced
with a field of possibility appeal to
possibilities in which several kinds of
conduct several ways of reacting and
modes of behavior are
available when they have a possibility
of doing otherwise than they actually
chose to do
they have enough freedom for them to be
called free in this case
so he says there is no face-to-face
confrontation of power and freedom as
mutually exclusive freedom disappearing
everywhere power x is exercised but a
much more complicated interplay
freedom may well appear as a condition
for the exercise of power at the same
time it's precondition since freedom
must exist for power to be exerted and
also its permanent support without the
possibility of recalcitrance that is
being you know resentful or not giving
in all the way power would be equivalent
to a physical determination
and so he says the crucial problem of
power is not that of voluntary servitude
how could we seek to be slaves he says
at the very heart of the power
relationship
and constantly provoking it people want
to use power because of these two things
are what
the recalcitrance of the will
and the intransigence
of freedom
we never quite know what other people
that we want to behave in reasonable way
we see it constrained ways
are going to do the waiter brings our
waters and plunks them down and some
water spills out and gets on the table
and we look at each other are they going
to do anything about this are they going
to mop it up and then they walk off and
we talk about it or you know complain
about it or whatever we are involved
in
power relations and we just got to see
the entrance the the intransigence of
the will the recalcitrance of the will
and the intransigence of freedom at play
right we could go on and on and on with
examples we could take a restaurant and
unpack it as an incredibly rich set of
power relations that are also part of
larger ones that have to do with fields
of possibilities
the one other thing that i want to bring
up is foucault says that we might use
a different word instead of talking
about an antagonism
it would be better to speak of an
agonism agon is a contest is a struggle
right of a relationship that is at the
same time mutual incitement and struggle
less of a face-to-face confrontation
that paralyzes both sides than a
permanent
provocation so this is he thinks that if
we get really specific about what power
relations involve we actually get to see
something like the essence of it where
we have at least two subjects
acknowledge the subjects
not necessarily in the same sort of
position as each other and there is a
uh determination actions
uh on other
actions rather just uh subjects on
subjects it's the possible fields of
their actions the fields of
possibilities that power really
bears upon
you